new york jets spoke to the media as well
here's robert sala
regarding having a younger quarterback
and obviously there will be a rookie
barring something unforeseen playing
quarterback this year in new york here's
new head coach robert sala
i i don't think there's risk you know it
still comes down to having a good
football team and building a good roster
around uh
uh around everybody i mean it's there's
players here that are talented there's
rookies that are going to be coming in
that are talented and i the the
expectation is that they're one of 53
when it's all said and done and they've
they've all got to perform their best to
create a great football team
and um so as as far as pressure is
concerned there's no pressure on me it's
just there's always pressure there's
always pressure to put put together the
best football team we possibly can
regardless of who's playing so
um uh very comfortable with uh every
decision that's made and it's our job to
get him to uh to put him in the best
position to be successful and that not
just the quarterback foot but every
single player that takes the field the
one thing that i can attest to is uh
from a schematic standpoint
uh
the scheme that lefleur is bringing is
is the best scheme in the world
so look we know they're taking zach
wilson at number two joe douglas the gm
of the team separately said that we
don't want to give everyone the answers
to our tests we already have the answers
to your test it is trevor lawrence and
it is zach wilson because if it wasn't
going to be zach wilson
they need to do at least something to
get people especially in new york
you need to get the people who write the
tabloid back page headlines you need to
get all of the hot take experts on radio
and tv in new york to understand there's
a chance it may not be zach wilson
because if all of a sudden they do the
switcheroo the presto chango they take
mack jones or justin fields or trey
lance folks are going to lose their
minds so the fact that there's been no
pushback about lawrence at one or wilson
at two tells me those are the first two
the draft begins at pick number three
miles
uh yeah i mean maybe he begins to pick
number three but i mean mac jones is now
uh the primitive favorite right the
betting favorite i guess i should say to
go to san francisco once today
yeah well that's that that's after it
was justin fields last week which is why
when we were doing the mock draft i
chose justin fields so who knows i don't
know but i i think you know when you're
looking at the jets it's interesting
that robert salas said oh you know
there's no pressure on the qb but it's
the pressure on the team to build things
around him and look i frankly don't
think that there's that much pressure on
the jets to get things right from a team
standpoint this year because look of
what they did last year all you have to
do is just show that you're building a
little bit of something and that can
come in late november december and into
january with the way this regular season
is now going to go with 17 games so
i just feel like at this point yes when
you know there is a rookie quarterback
coming in you don't want him to look bad
but you also need no you also know that
he doesn't need to look like the second
coming of joe namath you know from the
first snap i i think that as long as
they are putting some sort of quality
around zack wilson where you can say
look they look competitive they're
playing hard and then december they won
a couple of games
they're going to be all right so i i
think from that standpoint yeah what sal
is making what salla said makes a lot of
sense about wilson coming in and they're
not being too much pressure on him but
then you gotta factor in the new york
media market yeah there's always going
to be some pressure there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports